i've listened to all the writers master
classes and they all kind of say the
same thing
and it's you gotta sit in that chair and
it's you've got no idea
and then when you do have the idea you
have no idea where it came from
didn't come from you it's something that
came to you because you put the three
hours in or
however many hours in it came to you
and the language that mammoth put it in
was he said that
the character in the movie
goes if the writer didn't go through
what the character went through
it won't resonate it won't be good and
so when you have these surprise
it's the irony it's where like
inevitability meets
surprise um
it's because the author the person
writing that thing
i i just made a movie today i finished a
film
it's called breakthrough and it's about
that
it's about that that point that you get
to
um where you you need the breakthrough
and that's the point every time and i've
done over a thousand of these short
films
every time you're just like i quit i
this is it for me this is it i'm just
i could be a diesel mechanic that you
don't get this doesn't happen when
you're working on a diesel engine but it
does happen when you're working on a
diesel
and so if you've been doing it for years
and years and years and you've been
making these things and you're starting
to get conscious of these things
um one you can do them that they can
you can get more of them more quickly
you can get you can get these
breakthroughs more quickly but you have
to sit in the chair
and also you recognize them and you you
feel them coming it's very hard to
articulate
the job of it in the video you develop a
trust and a confidence that you will
have that breakthrough because it's
happened so many
that's right that's right even when
you're experiencing it you're like i
know
yeah i'm feeling it again but i just
have to keep going and then
once again just when you thought it was
never going to work out
you figure it out that's right in the in
a bit
in the video that i finished today that
when does when do you think this will
come out uh i don't know
you know not for a little bit okay good
so then it won't because this video i
did
will probably be out by the time this is
out
so um i do this thing where i say
you know like you hit the wall you hit
the wall with your project
and i say this i said thousands
thousands of walls every project has
this wall
since day one and then it cuts abruptly
the music cuts out everything
hammer cuts to mini dv footage
new york city shaky camera and it says
day one may 1st
2000 and then that wall
that's may 1st that wall the
breakthrough is november
17th okay now the breakthrough that i
needed to make this movie that you're
watching
i had two days to get that breakthrough
and i did it
and what to your point is that you
they do they come faster and you you get
accustomed and you get
you understand that right but i think
david mamet
articulating that for me and listening
to it and all of the writers
saying that's it they all judy bloom
says the same thing and there's this
this
and that's what you're seeing when you
see a good piece of writing is you're
seeing this struggle that
this guy learned that this guy didn't
know that going in or this gal
didn't know that going into writing this
thing
and and that's what you're seeing it's i
don't know it's just it's such a relief
to hear that coming from david mamet
because you just think
this guy you know is is gifted in a way
that i can't connect with
but if he's talking about this struggle
there's a there's a sense of
of comfort that can come over you when
it's visited upon you and just to hear
them say it
right
[Music]
[Music]
you